what is this
I think someone's getting [__]
that was great yeah what was that you
know there's a couple of aliens on the
top yeah some college aliens yeah you
know posting on top of the ship thing we
don't notice some college alien yeah
nice yeah I just pull over over here
it'll be fine yeah
I'm gonna [__] your brains out
laughs
so you're saying aliens landed on top of
the ship and then [__] yeah they're
like cruising behind their little bike
yeah okay yeah yeah like no one's good
enough yeah it's like having sex behind
a building yeah that's we just didn't
sit in our security out there to be like
how do you knock it off yeah get your 17
penises out of her [__] and they're
like
laughs
that's the sound that Jordan Peterson
makes
come on
yeah yeah give me
[Laughter]
[Music]
what if that dude's a Banshee what's a
banshee like uh like some like
Ben she put this dick in there
now what if he just just moans crazy
yeah like the second lady licks or you
know whatever he's into I was thinking
like how can you say I'm gonna come in a
Canadian accent like is there a word
like
oh on
like a like a slang term no I just mean
like what's a word that with the long o
that we could enunciate oh hmm I'm gonna
blow yeah yeah okay
yeah
how about
damn I can't think of that I know right
damn I'm sorry I'm sorry yeah yeah
that's yeah sorry I'm gonna burst I'm
sorry yeah
the Canadian way apologizing before you
nut all over
oops I'm sorry
you just spraying jizz all over this
person's stomach oops I'm sorry I'm
sorry
for roping
oh that's a lot of rope there you go
holy cow that's a lot of rope
I'm sorry I'm sorry so sorry
oh the holy cow I've left so much rope
all over your face
hey willikers that's a lot of rope
God bless anyone who's ever had a you
know wipe the [__] off their face I
thought you're gonna say [__] a Canadian
I was like
yeah well I think both of our ladies
that's my wife you're talking about yeah
both both of our ladies are doing that
charity yeah
yeah they're part of the Coalition of
women women [__] polite guys yeah
yeah
[Laughter]
I'm polite in that [__]
damn I love [__] shout out Michael
little priori he'd have this ad-lib
but he'd do on stream you say with
permission the permission
absolutely like can I eat you out with
permish
that's good the hell is this oh yeah
this is a whole story monks test
positive for meth what do you mean
becoming a monk I guess in certain areas
of the world it's not uh
it's not necessarily a religious thing I
think in Thailand it's almost like going
to military school if you're a bad kid
okay so I think
some uh you know
I see Bad actors in society are sent to
the temple to try to become better
people it's almost a weird rehab oh
that's that's my understanding of it so
it's not like you know
catching
some hyper-spiritual person I see also
doing math yeah yeah it's more like they
were doing math before and then they put
on these robes and they're not allowed
to go on their phone but they still want
to do math yeah they're just doing math
and looking dripped out of the time yeah
it did yeah you ever seen that Shaolin
monk documentary no
it's kind of interesting I don't know
how real it is what is it this is about
Shaolin Monks training Kung Fu and a
bunch of crazy [__] that they do okay
um
I don't know like hanging by their nuts
for 10 hours
now that's a traditional Buddhist thing
right yeah yeah you tie your balls to a
tree and you hang upside down
and meditate yeah they call it the
starfish yeah I mean you just
yeah no I don't know
we uh I one time I like gave offerings
to the monks I was in uh yes yes I did
now I was in
um
where the [__] was I like
um somewhere in Southeast Asia
I think
um Cambodia maybe but there was a
opportunity like in the city that I was
in every morning at like 4 30 a.m or
something like that the monks like
walked through the city and so you can
go and like give them offerings right
you can sit on the side and like offer
them food and stuff like that and
I did that and my friend who I was with
what did he offer we both had gone out
the night before okay
and so I was up till probably like 3 A.M
and then like fell asleep for an hour
and then woke up and he didn't go to bed
he went back with a girl cool and so he
was just doing the the complete polar
opposite thing that I was doing at that
moment in the morning I woke I was
giving offerings to the Monk and he was
he was indulging in adultery
literally what do you mean adultery is
cheating I know I mean no no I'm just
trying to find a fancy word for sex but
got it yeah coitus yeah coitus yeah yeah
but more of like a sinful
it's trying to like paint it as a sinful
thing you know I mean I was what I was
doing was very pure right and religious
yeah you know and he was doing blast he
was doing this blasphemous
he was Blasphemous penis yes indulging
oh I'm gonna Blasphemous penis
are you engaged in sex that's
blasphemous it sure is uh watch our
Blossom his penis
your mom likes blasphemy
yeah I saw her last night she was like
blasphemy
it's kind of a bar yeah
I'm a rapper sometimes you know
sometimes sometimes sometimes that's
good yeah dude that's hilarious what'd
you offer I forget it was like uh
please don't tell me you did like some
drunk Frank I think you walked out
through the [__] 40 I'm like
you need to take a load off man you
gotta leave your thinking a lot clink
yeah sorry it's kind of heavy
I know you got a long walk ahead of you
I know y'all work out though yeah you
conditioned for this [__] yeah all right
you're going up that mountain where
you're gonna need this
yeah I brought you a beer pong table
fold it up uh I would have got you the
full send one but they don't ship here
so
I brought you guys half a hot dog
I got last night I ate half before I
went to bed and I I wrapped it up in
tinfoil so you can have this they don't
have a fridge in the hostel so I
apologize it's just a little weird but
the monks are just staring at you
what dude
I wonder if they get you could say thank
you yeah I wonder if they get crazy [__]
I wonder if it's a weird social thing
where people it's like a weird pissing
contest oh yeah like what is imagine
someone just [__] it up everyone's
doing food
and you know kind of wholesome gifts for
a long time and then someone one day
just walks out there just puts a PS4 on
the [__] side yeah like um and the
Monk's like
oh
thank you yeah
or like a big bag of meth you heard you
guys like smoking that [__] yeah I heard
your boys go crazy up there
some guy all tatted up from the head
down like Smileys I think it would be
really funny to give them like an Oculus
yeah
there you go plug in metaverse
and then one of them's like nah we got
it it's ass yeah we have the Vibe back
at the temple we also have the valve
index way better
when we come back next week you mind
dropping off a G-Force
3870 ours fried because uh we were
mining Bitcoin and
uh it's not really profitable anymore so
it's not good for games